Jean-Marie legouen le secrétaire d'État
chargé des relation avec le Parlement et
l'invité de preu par 3 bonsoir et merci
d'être présent à ce rendez-vous de
Public Sénat avec l'Agence France Presse
représenté ce soir par Karine perz en
partenariat également avec del motion et
bien sûr Perin Tarnaud que l'on voit ici
de public sera également avec nous tout
à l'heure le débat tourne toujours
autour des réformes engagées par le
gouvernement Jean-Marie legouen engagé
ou promise d'ailleurs hein pour
débloquer l'économie française comme le
disent engagé déjà engagé déjà
dites-vous pour débloquer l'économie en
tous les cas comme le disent à la fois
le Premier ministre et puis le ministre
de l'Économie le débat tourne aussi
autour des difficultés de Paris pour
réduire son déficit et on le sait
Bruxelles France les sourcils nous en
parlerons donc tout à l'heure comme nous
évoqueront également la nouvelle donne
pour l'exécutif un sénat désormais à
droite mais d'abord je n'oublie pas
Jean-Marie legouen que vous êtes
également médecin et il y a une
inquiétude dans notre pays concernant
Ebola que comptez-vous faire au
gouvernement pour rassurer l'opinion on
a vu par exemple la peur irraisonné mais
que l'on peut comprendre de parents
d'élèves à Boulogne billancour alors
d'abord la première des choses c'est
évidemment d'avoir des dispositifs de
s'expliquer sur le dispositif puis
d'expliquer de quelle est la nature de
de cette épidémie donc le le virus Ébola
est un virus à l'évidence très dangereux
mortel dans bien des cas mais qui ne se
transmet que par un contact direct avec
les fluides d'un malade infecté ou d'une
personne morte d'ailleurs ça é le cas à
Madrid avec alors justement donc si vous
voulez ce ce qui fait que dans des
structures africaines je vais commencer
par là il faut une petite minute pas
plus mais dans des structures africaines
où on n' pas l'habitude où on a un deuil
avec les morts et cetera et
malheureusement la culture fait que il y
a une une capacité d'infection qui qui
se développe
mais théoriquement lorsque des soignants
avec du matériel sont en situation il
n'y a pas de de risque qu'il soit voà
mais je disais à Madrid il y a une alors
à Madrid ce qui s'est passé à Madrid aux
États-Unis il y a eu l'affaire au Texas
il y a eu apparemment des des fautes
d'assepsie c'est-à-dire de protection
par rapport à un malade infecté ou de
insuffisamment de suspicion et donc
ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a une
mutation du virus et que tout d'un coup
le virus serait plus facilement
transmissible bon alors l'affaire de
boulang Bill encour des parents j'allais
dire c'est une fausse alerte et
évidemment un peu juste parce que un
enfant semble-t-il rentrer de de
Guinée bon on peut comprendre
l'inquiétude des gens mais il faut bien
savoir que ça ne s'attrape pas comme la
grippe encore une fois il faut des
contacts avec des fuides et cetera mais
est-ce que vous pouvez dire par exemple
est-ce que nous sommes à l'abri d'une
épidémie parce que il y a quelques jours
des experts américains ont modélisé en
quelque sorte les risques ils ont donné
un pourcentage pour la France et même
une date prévisible à la fin du mois
d'octobre est-ce qu'il faut craindte
qu'il disent vrai non il peut y avoir
des malades infectés épmie il peut y
avoir des malades infectés qui arrivent
sur le territoire français comme sur
n'importe quel territoire européen ou
américain mais il y a toutes les
disposition c'est-à-dire à la fois des
services médicaux qui sont tout à fait
adaptés qui dès qu'un premier cas est
dépiste on y conduit le malade et on le
met sous quarantaine sous protection et
sous traitement sous prise en charge
médicale et deuxièmement des systèmes
qui sont des systèmes très connu
maintenant de de de de de si jamais
cette personne était passée comment
dirais-je un certain temps sur le
territoire national sans avoir bon assez
rapidement on sait comment contingenter
les personnes infectées donc on a on a
un système d'organisation qui est bien
protégé voilà après il y a un autre
mystère qui n'est qui est peu
vraisemblable c'est la mutation du virus
c'estàd que le virus muterait et
deviendrait plus transmissible mais en
règle générale oui mais en règle
générale si vous voulez il y a une règle
qui fait que plus un virus est mortel
moins il est transmissible voilà et donc
plus il est transmissible moins il est
dangereux et som par François Hollande a
dit que il a assuré que la France était
prête à soigner tout malade nous som pr
absolument on a un dispositif de de
prise en charge sanitaire qui est sans
doute un des meilleurs au monde
indiscutablement et d'un savoir-faire à
la fois des médecins des pouvoir public
Nour pas d'inquiétude non mais la
vigilance absolument pour ce qui se
passe d'abord en Afrique parce que on
pourrait on peut pas laisser quand même
l'Afrique à la dérive à la fois parce
que on est solidaire de de des
populations pas l'abandonner par exemple
totalement en coupant les liaisons
aériennes non c'est une faute c'est une
fausse bonne idée parce que si vous
voulez après les choses
d'abord il faut il faut lutter contre la
vraie transmission pas contre les fruses
transmission et il faut lutter y compris
là-bas ce que fait la France France qui
a envoyé médecins sans frontièrees
d'abord mais ensuite des troupes des
troupes excusez-moi mais c'est des des
systèmes de santé des armées qui qui va
là-bas qui en pleine forêt fait des des
équatoriales fait des choses très
importantes c'est alors le chef de
l'État s'est montré rassurant donc comme
vous un instant Françis c'est encore une
fois la France pratiquement en Europe
qui est la première sur ce type de
sujet non mais on va parler tout à
l'heure de voilà on va parler tout à
l'heure de la France qui n'est pas
toujours le meilleur élève de la classe
on va nous dire ça et en même temps
quand il s'agit de sécurité sanitaire ou
de sécurité face au terrorisme quand il
s'agit de solidarité la France elle est
en première ligne elle fait le travail
moi j'aimerais bien que l'Europe fasse
ce genre de chose voilà soit plus
présente dans la coalition
internationale qui compte une pay
compris
sanitaire sur la lutte pour les
médicaments enfin des choses comm ça bon
je la transition une âme une âme je la
transition est toute trouvée quand même
sur ce qui se passe en ce moment en Irak
et en Syrie avec l'organisation groupe
islamique les djihadistes sont donc
entrés dans la ville kurde de konabé en
Syrie malgré les raides aériens conduit
notamment par par les États-Unis en
priorité effectivement le président turc
erdoan ditil est-ce qu'il dit l'évidence
en plidant pour une une opération
terrestre qui montrerait là son
efficacité
oui indiscutablement les bombardements
ne suffiront pas attendez mais nous
avons toujours dit ça mais nous pensons
que c'est d'abord aux iraakiens de
régler cette question donc notamment à
la population kurde et à la et au
gouvernement et à l'armée irakienne et
s'agissant de cette ville après il faut
que les pays de la région qui ont un
intérêt direct dont la sécurité est
directement menacée euh j'allais dire
contact physique puisque cette ville
elle est à la frontière de la Turquie il
faut que en liaison avec le gouvernement
irakien on peut imaginer que un certain
nombre de pays et en l'occurrence la
Turquie se pose la question d'une
intervention au sol qui est plus naturel
plus aisé et plus vous dites qu'il
serait légitime que la Turquie
effectivement participe à des combats au
sol je pense que ça peut à partir du
moment où le gouvernement irakien et où
il y aurait en plus une prise en charge
juridique au plan de la communauté
internationale certaines conditions
peuvent être réunies pour que des forces
de la région interviennent hein sous un
contrôle des nations- Unies avec
l'accord du gouvernement iraakien mais
toujours sans la France B la France
n'ira pas
combattre au sol d'abord parce qu'on est
sur le territoire syrien vous savez que
la France pour l'instant est sur le
territoire irakien elle intervient par
avion par bombardement sur le territoire
iraakien n'intervient pas sur le
territoire syrien au plan aérien
deuxièmement elle n'intervient pas à
terre d'accord on va revenir aux
questions françaises l'UMP maintenant
tous les tous ces grands leaders qui
sont engagés dans une compétition pour
2017 sont d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
il faudra réécrire la loi tobira pour
sécuriser disyle Nicolas Sarkozi le dit
également maintenant la GPA et la PMA
est-ce que vous pensez que ce scénario
pour pas je sais pas si j'ai pas encore
bien compris moi ni si tous se sont
prononcés il me semble que Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire a dit des déclarations
qui étaient tout à fait contraire en
disant qu'on ne reviendrait pas je
pensais à Nicolas Sarkozy à François
monsieur aujourd'hui c'est Monsieur le
Maire qui est candidat au poste de
secrétaire général de l'UMP je ne suis
pas sûr que Monsieur Jupé ait dit ça non
plus et je suis sûr s que personne ne
reviendra sur cette loi aucune manière
mais bien sûr parce que là on parle pas
du principe même du mariage entre deux
personnes de même sexe on parle d'ajout
pour comme l'a dit l'ancien chef de
l'État sécuriser la
p il nous allait expliqué qu'il allait
mettre ça dans la Constitution c'est une
rigolade c'est une rigolade on va pas
mettre dans la Constitution toutes les
choses dont on a peur que soi-même ell
ne soi pas appliqué et qu'on ne les
appliquera pas donc tout ça c'estoudreux
oui c'est de la poudre aux yeux
mais bien sûr il y a une course à
l'échalotte pour récupérer ce noyau dur
de militant de droite et chaque candidat
de droite euh enfin pas tous d'ailleurs
mais certains plus que d'autres aussi
des vois à gauche qui s'élèv contre la
GPA vous le savez hein non mais contre
la GPA bien sûr mais personne a demandé
l'inscription de la Constitution mais
voilà c'est c'est donc il y a pas besoin
d'en rajouter et personne ne dit
personne à gauche et personne de sensé
ne peut dire qu'il y a dans la loi
tobira une inclinaison vers la GPA c'est
c'est un mensonge c'est un fantasme qui
est donc je veux dire ça ça ne touchera
pas la problématique de la riture de la
loi donc je dis il n'y aura pas de
réécriture de la loi et d'ailleurs les
Français ne veulent pas vous dites même
en cas d'alternance il n'y aura pas de
réécriture bien sûr oui je l'affirme
aujourd'hui absolument et j'aimerais que
il y ait un engagement pris par les
candidats de droite en disant qu'ils
vont re mettre en cause la loi tobira
ils le disent dans tous les cas pour
l'instant non il disent pas qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire la réécrit c'est quoi
qu'on nous dise ce qu'il ce dont il
s'agit quel est l'article qu' veulent
faire sauter qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
dire en tous les cas à ce stade vous ne
les croyez pas un mot sur Nicolas
Sarkozi tiens il dit que les procédures
judiciaires qui se multiplient presque
une par jour en ce moment ont renforcé
sa détermination est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une bonne motivation
effectivement pour lui non je pense que
ça laisse à penser mais je ne veux pas
le croire que sa motivation principale
c'est de régler des affaires
personnelles donc soit pour croit-il se
mettre à l'abri soit pour au contraire
essayer comme il le dit par ailleurs de
de de de sauver son honneur mais dans
les deux cas de figure c'est pas ça le
sujet une élection présidentielle c'est
d'apporter une réponse au pays c'est pas
d'apporter une réponse à soi-même donc
je pense que ces formules moi que j'ai
entendu m'ont étonné m'ont un peu choqué
oui h on va parler dans un instant du du
budget Jean-Marie legouen des
difficultés pour trouver les économies
et surtout pour convaincre la commission
de Bruxelles un mot sur les réformes qui
sont déjà engagé vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure on entend manuel Vals à Londres
Emmanuel Macron dans un portrait que
dresse de lui le New York Times évoquer
des sujets tabou jusque-l hein le
ministre de l'économie qui dénonce
l'amas de protection légale des
travailleurs en France le Premier
ministre qui dit que la question de
l'assurance chômage doit être posée on n
plus dans on n plus dans même pas dans
le social libéralisme là on est dans le
libéralisme tout court non non pas du
tout ce ce que ce qui est dit d'abord
c'est des propos qui sont indirectement
rapportés là aussi j'allais dire ils ne
sont pas suffisamment précisés non non
mais j'entends par là de la part des
journalistes on a des citations assez
précises du Premier ministre he Quiou
mais je vous dis qui évoque la durée le
montant des animisations chômage par
exemple et qui vente le modè britannique
scandinave en l'occurrence plutôt il
était à Londres oui oui mais le modèle
britannique n n'est pas exactement le
même c'estàdire que nous trouvons et je
pense que beaucoup de Français trouvent
que effectivement il y a par exemple
tout un système de de montant de
rémunération maintenu queles que soient
les conditions qui pose un certain
nombre de questions ça doit faire partie
du débat ça sera dans le débat y compris
dans le débat social dans les mois qui
viennent puisqu'il y aura une
renégociation dans les mois qui viennent
ou c'est que les syndicats ils veulent
pas entendre parler d'une plus grande
dégressivité des allocations chômage
hein vous le savez mais peut-être mais
comme par ailleurs mais vous dites c'est
un frein le système actuel est un frein
à la reprise du travail oui puis par par
certains aspects il estest parce qu'il y
a aussi on le sait des gens qui
justement ont un certain niveau de
rémunération de substitution qui
faitè par exemple qui pour lequel on
peuvent se dire légitimement dans le
système actuel je peut attendre 6 mois 1
an avant de rechercher un travail
surt instant un candidat à la présidence
de de a sai que c'est une partie
importante de son programme exactement
ce que vous dites là mais écoutez ce
c'est pas parce que on dit qu'il faut
par exemple des marches pour les
entreprise que c'est la gauche le dit la
droite le dit peut-être en tout cas elle
l'a pas fait nous on essaie de poser
raisonnablement les choses sans défaire
le modèle social ce que j'entends de ce
que disent les gens de droite
aujourd'hui plus que Monsieur le Maire
c'est on va faire 100 milliards
d'économie sans nous dire véritablement
comment moi je sais comment on fait 100
milliards d'économies c'est vous allez
devoir déjà vous expliquer sur comment
on fait 21 milliards d'économies 50
milliards jusqu'en 2017 puisqu'on va
parler du budget maintenant vous êtes
d'accord Jean-Marie legouen on va ouvrir
ce débat donc avec Karine Peret de
l'Agence France Presse elle arrive juste
après cette présentation par Samia
dechir des chiffres clés et donc le
premier d'entre eux bien ce sont ces
fameux 21 milliards d'euros
d'économie 21 milliards d'euros
d'économie en 2015 la France devra se
serrer la ceinture dans le projet de
budget du gouvernement l'effort sera
réparti entre l'État à hauteur de 7,7
milliards d'euros les collectivités
locales qui seront privées de de 3,7
milliards et la protection sociale où
9,6 milliards d'économies sont annoncé
l'exécutif estime avoir fait un effort
historique seulement pour la droite le
compte n'y est pas il est tout à fait
clair que le budget qui nous est
présenté ne respecte pas la trajectoire
pluri-annuelle des finances publiques ne
respecte pas la parole de la France et
que les efforts de réduction de dépenses
prétendument fait au niveau de 21
milliards eur ne sont pas suffisamment
documentés pour qu'on puisse y croire
très remonté aussi les frondeurs
dénoncent au contraire une austérité
contre prodoductive qui risque selon eux
d'aggraver la récession je pense que
dans le projet de loi de finances qu'on
nous propose de voter la semaine
prochaine il y a une hérésie qui est la
baisse des dotations de près de 4
milliards d'euros aux collectivités
locales qui sont le principal
investisseur public aujourd'hui
critiquer de toutes part le budget 2015
risque en plus d'être retoqué par la
Commission européenne car même avec 21
milliards d'économie le déficit
atteindra 4,3 % du PIB bien au-delà des
3 % exigés par Bruxell impossible de
faire plus dit l'exécutif dont la marge
de manœuvre est très réduite il faudrait
aller encore plus loin dans les
économies mais on voit bien qu'on arrive
aussi à une certaine limite et le danger
c'est si on va plus loin aussi on va
aggraver les effets récessifs de ces
politique là donc on est effectivement
entre deux situations d'un côté
Bruxelles qui voudrait qu'on fasse plus
d'effort et de l'autre côté l'économie
la situation économique qui
nécessiterait d'en faire au contraire
moins donc on trouvera le le la ligne on
est vraiment sur une ligne de crête dans
lesquelle il est très difficile de
trouver de faire des bons choix le bras
de fer est déjà engagé avec la
commission qui réclame plus d'économie
ironie du sort c'est au français Pierre
Moscovici probable futur commissaire
européen aux finances qu'il reviendra de
faire appliquer les règles européennes à
l'Hexagone voilà bonsoir Karine perz
bonsoir vos questions à Jean-Marie
logouen sur cette question d'une très
très grande importance et autement
polémiqueou oui euh plusieurs voix à
Bruxelles disent que la France va devoir
revoir sa copie car le le le déficit est
trop élevé si demain Bruxelles vous
demande de faire 8 milliards d'euros
d'économie en plus comment est-ce que
vous allez faire mais d'abord euh
Bruxelles peut faire des commentaires
elle ne fait pas le budget en France le
budget en France il est voté par
l'Assemblée nationale par le Sénat par
le Parlement oui mais la Commission peut
retoquer le budget elle va l'examiner
dans faire des crities non non après
c'est un dans un deuxème temps et c'est
pas au niveau de la commission c'est au
niveau du conseil donc euh si vous
voulez c'est dans un premier temps il y
a la commission qui fait des remarques
qui fait des critiques qui peut donc
s'exprimer ce qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs
de façon assez régulière parce que je
conteste en dehors de lesfféobè vous
savez on est dans une situation un peu
particulière vous avez une commission
qui s'en va c'està direire qu'ils vont
être ils seront plus commissaire voilà
Baroso monsieur Barroso est un monsieur
et sa com mission était très marquée
j'allais dire sur une ligne très
libérale d'une part et assez peu
francophile d'autre part et s'en allant
étant d'ailleurs pas très content de la
manière dont on les a remercié peut-être
qu'il y avait des raisons de les
remercié comme on les a remercié ils
font des remarques qui ne sont pas très
sympathiques potentiellement c'est
possible et bien nous allons discuter
sérieusement parce que nous avons des
arguments à faire valoir et on n'est pas
le l'élève qui passe devant des
commissaires qui seront il vous voit
comme le mauvais élève hein oui mais si
vous voulez ce genre
d'attitude explique d'ailleurs donc il a
pas il y aura pas d'économie
supplémentaire le le budget va passer il
y a pas besoin de faire
d'économies av supplémentairire de voir
de
remettreerme je vous confirme que nous
avons un budget sérieux et que nous
allons le défendre sérieusement voilà et
que nous sommes prêts avec beaucoup de
comment dirais-je capacité de dialogue à
discuter des questions qui nous seront
posées et nous apporteront un certain
nombre de réponses mais on ne va pas se
faire
morigêner par une commission dont le
substrat démocratique reste encore un
peu interrogatif pour quelques jours et
et et et après nous discuterons avec
l'ensemble des gens puisque nous sommes
dans une Union européenne nous avons et
c'est bien normal à présenter nos
éléments budgétaires nous le mais pas
sur un mode d'un enfant qui se fait
gronder mais dans la nouvelle dans la
nouvelle Commission pardon pierre
moscovissi va peut-être vouloir montrer
son indépendance par rapport à la France
est-ce que la France peut aller au clash
avec la nouvelle Commission mais encore
une fois nous ne sommes nous ne pensons
pas que nous allons au clash je veux
dire nous ne prenons pas pour argent
compant si j'ose dire les rumeurs qui
existent aujourd'hui à Bruxelles sur la
manière dont on ferait des des
commentaires sur Premier ministre s'est
quand même exprimé là-dessus hier
l'Élysée également donc en disant en
disant qu'il se considérit comme
optimiste mais mais c'est ce que je dis
c'est ce que j'essaie de vous dire mais
non seulement je dis que je suis
optimiste j'essaie de vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est que un nous avons un bon
budget de nous allons argumenter tris
nous ne sommes pas en train de nous
faire noter ou de nous faire morigêner
je reprends ce terme par euh par la
commission surtout par une commission
finissante n som sérieux logique de la
commission sortante là qui n'aimait pas
tellement la France dites-vous est-ce
que la la nouvelle qui se met en place
effectivement S D clair je vais être
encore plus clair la commission sortante
qui est là depuis 5 ans est donc
responsable de la gestion enfin en
partie responsable de la gestion de la
crise après 2008 ça a été et ça c'est
conçu ce que je vais vous dire c'est le
jugement du
FMI de l'OCDE de la plupart des grands
économistes la manière dont la zone euro
a été gérée après la crise de 2008 a été
une véritable erreur c'està-dire que
quand voz les
États-Unis extrêmement impressionnés
nous sommes extrêmement impressionnés
intellectuellement si je peux me
permettre nous sommes extrêmement
impressionnés intellectuellement par
cette commission puisque elle a eu elle
a elle a mérité elle de recevoir les
félicitations vous y Notter mon ironie
de la part du FMI de l'OCDE et elle même
a commencé voilà la commission dit que
certains dans les cercles du pouvoir
vous allez peut-être voir confirmer
nourissent peut-être un sentiment du
complot en disant bah c'est en fait le
bras armé de la toute la droite
européenne contre la France Monsieur
Junker non c'est pas mon sentiment mais
je crois pas que ce soit du tout l'état
d'esprit d'ailleurs c'est pas l'histoire
de Monsieur Junker et c'est pas l'état
d'esprit dans lequel on aborde monsieur
Barroso avait l'histoire de cette
commission était lourde je je viens d'en
rappeler quelques éléments là Monsieur
Junker il a fait pour tout ce que nous
avons entendu jusqu'à présent monsieur
Junker était assez intéressant hein les
fameux 300 milliards d'investissement il
faut discuter et cetera et et nous
pensons que la manière dont les choses
ont été faites jusqu'à présent vont
plutôt dans le bon sens la manière dont
la BCE évolue et la manière dont
finalement monsieur Junker a l'air de de
de considérer que il est plutôt bien que
la BCE évolue dans ce sens-là tout ça
est assez positif donc mais par ailleurs
nous nous sommes contents de notre copie
jeis pas dire c'est parce quecord sur ce
point alors on a des questions question
vous a parl dialogue nous allons
dialoguer oui vous avez parlé
d'investissement là je vous parle des
investissements en France les
collectivité territorial on l'a vu dans
le reportage vont avoir leur part
d'économie à faire 3,7 milliard d'euros
d'économie martineo bris dit très
inquiettete pour le secteur de des
investissements le logement euh
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez mais il y a il y a un dialogue
aujourd'hui entre le groupe majoritaire
et parlementair de la majorité sur cette
idé d' invvestissement il est évident la
rapporteur du budget qui propose un
amendement qui permettrait aux
collectivités locales de récupérer de la
TVA est-ce que vous le soutiendrez cet
amendement c'est une piste qui est
intéressante elle est aujourd'hui
examinée par le gouvernement il est
exacte que les collectivités
territoriales sont dans un cycle où nous
devons soutenir leur investissement en
même temps il est absolument évident que
il est légitime que les collectivités
territoriales participent à hauteur de
ce qu'ell pèseent dans le budget de
l'ensemble de de de la
colctiv voilà et il est important
qu'elle qu'elle puisse participer voilà
donc une piste intéressante il y a il y
a un dialogue qui est établi j'ai bon
espoir qu'il aboutisse à trouver le
réglage fin qui permette effectivement
de faire des économies d'abord sur le
fonctionnement et qui ne pénalise pas en
priorité le l'investissement vous
craignez à nouveau des débats ouleux au
moment du vote du budget est-ce que vous
vous pouvez vous épargner le recours à
l'article 493 écoutez j'étais en réunion
ce matin du groupe socialistes alors je
n'oublie pas les radicaux les
écologistes et cetera mais nous avons
lesurs socialistes qui disent qu'il
peuvent pas voter l'État le budget
pardon en l'état écoutez ça fait
plusieurs fois ça fait maintenant la 5e
ou la 6e fois qu'il nous disent ça à
chaque fois il y a eu une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale pour voter les
textes budgétaires la confiance voilà
donc je suis pas plus inquiet cela donc
pas
493 écoutez le 493 existe dans la
Constitution mais là je ne vois pas la
nécessité à priori de de l'utiliser on
verra s'il y avait une attitude de la
part de de des uns ou des autres qui
veulent bloquer absolument le débat on
peut toujours se poser des questions
mais c'est pas je crois l'état d'esprit
dans lequel sont qui que ce soit je
pense qu'il y a aussi des leçons qui ont
été tirées de de ces dernières semaines
et ces derniers mois je pense qu'une
certain type d'attitude où on voyait les
socialistes se diviser entre eux comme
étant le premier spectacle des plateaux
de télévision est considéré quand même
par beaucoup d'électeurs et compris de
gauche par beaucoup de militants du
Parti socialiste comme n'étant pas la
voie à suivre je pense que ça ses
limites donc ces limites elles ont été
intégrées donc on passe à autre chose et
en plus vous avez vu je je l'ai dit
quand on est à à
4,3 de déficit budgétaire dire qu'on
fait de l'austérité c'est pas ça c'était
le mot de d'Arnaud
mondbourg j'ai pas bien compris
l'obsession du gouvernement et c'est
l'erreur du quinen j'entends mais je
comprends pas bien ce qu'il veut dire
par là je je comprends pas bien à moins
qu'il ait lui-même un objectif bon
surtout cararnaud il a un objectif oui
non non je parle économique surtout que
bah ça peut de temps en temps on peut
faire aux élus de d'avoir des des
convictions sur le fond et pas
simplement des des des positions de de
de combat politique donc le gouver
Arnaud lui-même a toujours été Arna
Montebourg a toujours été quand il était
ministre de l'Économie et bien avant
très soucieux des déficit public quand
il a soutenu François Hollande dans la
primaire il savait et c'était aussi
parce que François Hollande avait dit
que son objectif c'était de ramener les
3 % le déficit de ramener au 3 % qui ne
sera pas aussi rapidement le cas qu'on
ne pouvait l'espérer en raison du fait
que la croissance européenne n'est pas
suffisamment bonne que la France ne
s'est pas suffisamment réformé tout ça
est exact donc nous faisons un un un
mixte en quelque sorte entre la
nécessité effectivement de diminuer la
dépense publique mais de le faire à un
rythme qui est pas trop brutal à un
moment où la consommation
l'investissement la consommation des
ménages est un des principaux moteurs de
l'activité économique si nous étouffions
par des prélèvements trop importants par
une diminution de la dépense publicque
trop important nous étoufferions la
croissance économique et quelque part on
aurait un déficit encore plus important
c'est par exemple quand la droite
propose 100 milliards d'économie c'est
pas simplement la destruction d'un
modèle social mais c'est une erreur
économique parce que à vouloir trop
prélever de l'argent public brutalement
sur l'économie on aboutit à ce moment-là
à l'effet inverse de ce que l'on peut
constater c'est-à-dire un tel
ralentissement de la croissance que bah
les recettes de l'État ne rentrent plus
et donc à partir de là et bien vous avez
une augmentation du déficit sur la
partie famille des des budgets juste
justement le gouvernement prévoit 700
millions d'euros d'économie sur la
famille Marisol Touren s'est dit ouverte
à des aménagements quand Christian etart
dit que les 700 millions d'euros sont
immuables alors est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à des évolutions sur ces sujets
alors d'abord il faut rappeler que nous
avons augmenté les prestations familles
depuis 2 ans de d'un milliard d'euros
bien aujourd'hui nous les corrigeons à
la fois avec un effet d'enveloppe comme
vous dites c'està dire 700 millions
parce qu'il faut 700 millions par
rapport à de la progression que vous
êtes capable est-ce que vous serez
d'accord pour changer les choses sur le
congé parental sur peut y avoir il peut
y avoir j'allais vous
répondre j'allais vous répondre je ne
pense pas que nous reviendrons sur la
masse d'argent demandé il peut y avoir
des mouvements qui se font sur quelles
sont les mesures les plus appropriées
pour obtenir un rendement économique qui
est CELI vous ditou alors concrètement
est-ce que parler de rendement c'est un
peu concrètement c'est un débat
parlementaire donc c'est pas le ministre
des Relations avec le Parlement qui
avant que débat n'est eu lieu et en
commission et le texte présenté en
Conseil des ministres et le débat à
l'intérieur de l'Assemblée nationale va
dire hop la récréation est terminée
c'est moi qui décide le groupe PS a
suggéré la mise sous condition de de
desocation une piste qui fait il y a le
débat se poursuit il y a a une vraie
interrogation en tout cas il y a pas
d'esprit de fermeture de la part du
gouvernement à partir du moment où il y
a des grands équilibres économiques qui
sont maintenus il y a une vraie
réflexion avec les parlementaires pour
savoir ce qui est qui est le plus
efficace d'un mot est-ce que est-ce que
Arna Montebourg Benoît Hamont Martine
auri vous font peur oh bah écoutez non
pourquoi personne me fait peur ni eux ni
d'autres ils sont dans mon parti dis
qu'il représentent maintenant la
majorité de au parti et veulent un
congrès au non je crois pas même pas
qu'il disent ça non plus d'ailleurs mais
c'est parce que j'entends moi j'ai
l'oreille
peut-être se dit le point d'équilibre
entre le PS et voir les écologistes et
le ben vous voyez mais c'est déjà plus
tout à fait é socialiste dans cons du
par socialiste non mais j'ai pas avoir
peur de camarades qui défendent des
idées dont deux étaient membres du
gouvernement de Jean-Marc erud puis de
Manuel Vals et qui ont je le pense
plutôt fait bien leur travail on sait
dans quelles conditions ils ont ils ont
quitté le gouvernement c'était un peu
pas forcément leur volonté c'était un
peu un accident par des paroles
malheureuses bon donc je veux dire j'ai
pas peur de ce qu'ils peuvent dire même
si je comprends bien aussi qu'ils
souhaitent aujourd'hui sffirm ce qui est
parfaitement légitime alle merci
beaucoup Karine allez Perinn Public
Sénat arrive maintenant pour évoquer la
nouvelle donne constituée par l'élection
d'un Sénat de droite Jean-Marie legouen
à ce stade on note pas de volonté
d'obstruction si ça peut vous rassurer
Louis
cbil un Sénat à droite et si ce n'était
pas pour le gouvernement une si terrible
nouvelle pendant 3 ans sa propre
majorité ne votait pas toutes les lois
et bien des signes indiquent que la fin
de cette parenthèse de gauche ne se dura
pas par des crispations à répétition
Gérard Larcher l'a annoncé dès le début
de sa présidence à la majorité je veux
m'adresser pour lui dire qu'une tâche
lattend est une opposition constructive
avec pour boussol l'intérêt du pays en
ces tant de difficultés opposition
constructive la formule est lâchée de
quoi faire plaisir au centristes qu'
avait posé comme condition à leur
aliment à l'UMP on veut un sénat qui
vraiment fasse des propositions on veut
un sénat qui construise on veut un sénat
qui vote les lois d'où qu'elles viennent
y compris du gouvernement si elles vont
dans le bon sens parce que la situation
de la France exige aujourd'hui de pas
être dans le blocage tout de même le
gouvernement serait avisé de ne pas
nourrir trop d'illusion 2017 est dans
toutes les têtes et sur les textes jugés
fondamentaux l'opposition jouera son
rôle moi j'ai toujours dit qu'il n' aura
pas de réflexe pavlovien d'opposition
quand il faudra protéger les Français de
textes que nous jugerons toxi et bien
nous nous opposerons euh quand le
gouvernement ouvrira le débat nous
débattrons et nous construirons quand le
Sénat veut grogier il sait grogier il
est clair qu'il y a des sujets sur
lequel on veut que le Sénat soit
respecté la réforme territoriale on ne
comprendrait pas qu'il y ait pas une
deuxième lecture c'est évident qu'il y a
quand même peu de chance que nous
votions le budget du gouvernement
socialiste il y a assez peu de chance
qu'un certain nombre de textes passe
facilement dans le cadre des réforme
proposé si l'Assemblée nationale a de
toutes les façons le dernier mot reste à
savoir si le gouvernement sa autorisera
à ne pas tenir compte des avis et des
débats du Sénat alors on va voir
justement quel sort vous voulez réserver
à ce Sénat bonsoir père inter ou quel
sort va réserver le Sénat bonsoir Michel
bonsoir Jean-Marie Logen quand même
quand on écoute les sénateurs de de
droite qui viennent de s'exprimer dans
dans ce reportage ils sont plutôt de
bonnes composition ça va être plus
simple peut-être pour vous à gérer le
Sénat de droite que le Sénat de gauche
qui ne voteit pas les textes oui je ne
dirais pas ça mais en tout cas le les
élections ont eu lieu donc moi je suis
là pour pour constater qu'il y a une
nouvelle majorité au Sénat et je me
félicite de de ces engagements je pense
que le pays a besoin aujourd'hui
euh à la fois d'une opposition
constructive et je dirais que le Sénat a
besoin aussi d'un travail constructif
parce que euh on le voit bien il y a
depuis un certain temps des
interrogations d'ailleurs depuis
longtemps parce que général de Gaulle
lui-même c'était déjà interrogé sur la
question du S du Sénat voilà et donc VO
arme attention non c'est pas une arme du
tout c'est le Sénat est menacé mais pas
du tout c'est pas une arme je pense que
les sénateurs en ont pris tout à fait
conscience et qu' savent ce qu'ils ont à
faire c'est pas à moi de leur dire mais
tout ça ce sont des des des choses
absolument évidentes le pays a besoin
d'une opposition constructive et non pas
d'une opposition de posture on vient de
parler du budget à l'instant si vous
trouvez un seul endroit où l'opposition
a soutenu la majorité dans une
diminution de la dépense vous me ferez
signe la dépense la défense non la
famille non euh euh la police non la
culture non les collectivités
territoriales non ils sont pour la
défense je viens de le dire non et
cetera donc si vous voulez il y a 100
milliards de d'économie à faire mais il
y a pas un endroit où là on nous a dit
ce qu'il fallait faire en
diminution ce que j'appelle pas une
opposition constructive ce qui
m'intéresserait dans l'opposition
constructive ce qui serait intéressant
surtout pour les Français c'est qu'on
nous dise et le Sénat va peut-être nous
le dire comment ils vont faire pour
faire ces économies de 100 milliards il
par budget le fait que le Sénat vote pas
Bud budget qui va être voté par le Sénat
de on va voir si le Sénat ce que le
Sénat propose ça c'est intéressant mais
sur quel texte vous pourriez trouver des
axes de concertation de conciliation
avec la droite est-ce que par exemple
sur la réforme territoriale qui va être
l'axe majeur he ici de discussion de
débat au Sénat cet automne il peut y
avoir une voie pour le département pour
le Sénat le
département mais de proposer notamment
d'abord sur découpage région une
nouvelle carte des régions bah est-ce
qu'il y a une marge de manœuvre possible
pour le
Sénat peut-être il faut il faut écouter
ce que va nous dire le Sénat je ne sais
pas nous ce qu'a dit le président de la
République c'est qu'il était attaché à
ce que globalement on sorte pas des 13
voilà 13 ou 14 régions bon si le Sénat a
des propositions à faire et s'il
convain du bon sens tout le monde bah on
va avancer les bonnes idées elles sont
là pour avancer maintenant si vous
voulez me trouver une conciliation sur
la réforme territoriale si j'entends
François Fillon qui a l'air bien
représenté au Sénat non mais il est bien
représenté si j'ai bien compris il dit
il y aura plus que deux niveaux alors là
va falloir nous on est moins ambitieux
que François Fillon mais on va voir ce
que va nous dire le Sénat si dit il faut
maintenir cinq niveaux euh je veux dire
je je préférerais Fillon que le Sénat
filloniste donc je sais pas voyez qu
quelle va être les propositions réelles
du Sénat entre le discours qui est tenu
au plan national le budget les réformes
territoriales et la réalité ça va être
intéressan juste pour rester juste pour
finir sur la réforme territoriale quel
va être le calendrier parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'interrogations ici au sat
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une deuxième
lecture sur le redécoupage des
région ex nous avons toujours dit que à
partir du moment où il y avait des
engagements sur lequels il n'y aurait
pas d'obstruction nous étions favorables
à une deuxième lecture voilà rapidement
là dans les dans les semaines à venir à
partir du moment où il y a pas
d'obstruction programmé on a des
engagements d'un travail serein
raisonnable une semaine de travail et
tout ça est parfait h euh on vous
parliez du Sénat baching tout à l'heure
Claude Bartelone dans un livre
propose-lui de supprimer la fonction
législative du Sénat le bicamérisme n'a
plus lieu d'être en France non c'est pas
ma position j'ai eu l'occasion de de
m'exprimer je pense que le
bicamérisme a un sens je pense que le
Sénat tel qu'il est a du sens que il a
pu à à certaines époques compris sous
des gouvernements de gauche c'est-à-dire
avec un sénat de droite à apporté des
choses qui étaient tout à fait
intéressantes encore faut l' opinion de
de Bartelone mais c'est aussi l'opinion
de de certains députés socialistes qui
ont publié dernièrement une tribune donc
c'est une idée qui circulle à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que ça vous
gêne vous qui est chargé de trouver un
équilibre rappelle que c le premier qui
à ma connaissance à parleré de ça de
supprimer le Sénat c'était le général de
Gaulle donc vous voyez la gauche n'a pas
le monopole des idées d'une
simplification ou d'une de de de d'une
margin enfin suppression le mot est trop
fort mais de de d'évolution forte du
Sénat donc la question elle est posée
pas par la gauche elle est posée
seulement et et j'allais dire pas
principalement par la gauche elle est
posée mais ce n'est pas la position
actuelle pardon c'est quand même
essentiellement des propositions qui
viennent de la gauche aujourd'hui je ne
suis pas certain que avant la fin du
mandat vous ayez pas vous entendiez pas
autre chose de la part de la droite
alors sur les question sur les questions
institutionnelles justement pour
l'instant en tout cas dans les tuyaux N
on regarde les propositions qui viennent
de la gauche qui viennent notamment du
président de la République est-ce qu'il
faut supprimer diminuer pardon le nombre
de
parlementaires c'est ce que c'est une
idée alors là qui est largement partagée
à gauche et à droite le président de la
République a dit des choses en ce sens
il me semble que Monsieur Nicolas
Sarkozi a dit récemment des choses qui
vont dans ce sens il me semble que
Monsieur Fillon a dit des choses qui
vont dans ce sens et que peut faire le
chef de l'État à l'absence de majorité
des 35e ça ne passe pas par une
modification cons alors justement quelle
réformme peut-il faire en matière
institutionnelle écoutez il y a un débat
institutionnel rampant dans ce pays
c'est-à-dire que euh en fait nos
concitoyens ne se nent pas le matin en
disant au fait réfléchissons aux
nouvelles institutions mais
objectivement quand vous voyez des
responsables politiques de gauche et de
droite beaucoup nous disent et beaucoup
se disent et peut-être que nous sommes
nombreux à nous dire que euh le
fonctionnement du quinquena euh des
élections législatives qui sont juste
après les élections présidentielles euh
certains S sur le bicamérisme sur le bon
et cetera et sur la problématique de la
proportionnelle toutes ces questions
sans parler du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature du droit de vote des
imigrés et C et dernière année actu
écoutez François Hollande a dit qu' que
lui il avait ses idées en tête qu'il y
réfléchissait il va attendre quoi la fin
du quinena mais je je pense qu'il y a un
débat politique c'est les
institutions ça peut demander à ce qu'il
y ait un certaine forme de murissement
quand même euh que qu'il y a une
appropriation dans le débat voilà on
peut pas faire des réformes qui seraient
aussi importantes et qui tout d'un coup
ne correspondrai pas euh à à une
maturation de l'esprit je dis pas un
consensus parce que je crois pas au
consensus ni sur ce sujet ni sur
d'autres mais euh est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir un compromis est-ce que est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une maturation est-ce
que est-ce que les choses vont
clairement on va dire une option a une
option B diminution du nombre de
parlementaires comme la proportionnelle
ça suppose pas de modification
constitutionnelle donc ça peut être une
simple loi qui
va il est utile de faire des lois qui
correspondent à un projet politique
global et qui sont acceptés dans la
société bien bien alors le député Julien
hbert sanctionné à l'Assemblée nationale
pour avoir refusé d'appeler candrine
mazotier madame la Présidente est-ce que
c'est une interpré une interprétation du
règlement complètement disproportionné
comme le dit Christian Jacob le patron
des députés UMP écoutez moi je je n'ai
pas alors là vraiment ma fonction
ministérielle m'interdit de gérer dans
les problèmes de règlement interne de
l'Assemblée c'est donc c'est le
gouvernement c'est un incident de séance
hier mais c'est justement parce que
c'est un incident de séance entre des
parlementaires sur le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale que ça n'interfère
en rien il y a eu là pendant une
demi-heure juste avant vous des rappel
au règlement un débat à aucun moment le
gouvernement n'est rentré dans cette
discussion voilà par ailleurs
l'Assemblée nationale a un
règlement voilà elle juge comme elle
l'entend la manière dont elle fait
appliquer son règlement mais c'est très
ce n'est pas le gouvernement n'a aucune
autorité sur le règlement de l'Assemblée
ni à l'Assemblée nationale ni au Sénat
parce que si je devais avoir
aussi un point de vue sur le règlement
du Sénat et sur son application ça
poserait d'autres questions ouis enfin
en tout cas on a pu entendre dans lesc
l'assemblée il vaut mieux s'appeler
Thomas tevenou que Julien Aubert si on
veut toucher ses indemnités ça c'est en
référence au députés qui n'a pas
démissionné qui ne vient plus beaucoup à
l'Assemblée FA et pas faire n'importe
quelle comparaison voilà je le pense
vraiment la démagogie à certaines
limites h et qu'est-ce que vous pensez
du de la présence toujours alors de
Monsieur tevenou je me suis déjà exprimé
là-dessus euh ouis mais la situation
perdure mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que nous y fassions la Constitution fait
que c'est pas le gouvernement qui peut
destituer un parlementaire ça ça vous
vous me suggérez pas que je puisse
destituer des parlementaires bon alors
voilà donc la question est bonne les
radigau de de gauche Conseil national
demain matin euh faut-il ou non rester
au gouvernement c'est la question qui va
être posée au parti au membres du
Conseil national du parti Radal de
gauche il a eu sous la pression de
Jean-Michel Bay qui est en colère ça
tangue oui oui oui oui oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai parce que Jean-Michel yet le
sentiment il a subi il n'a pas été réélu
dans son département il y a il y voit
une grande blessure et je le comprends
une responsabilité du Parti socialiste
il a raison je pense que si vous regarde
de près je pense que ce n'est pas
totalement exact il y a pu avoir dans
d'autres départements euh des des
dysfonctionnements à l'intérieur de la
gauche et des gens qui d'ailleurs ont
été critiqués par le Parti socialiste
voir exclus du parti socialiste qui ont
pu contribuer à ce qui est des
parlementaires qui des des élus radicaux
qui ne soient pas élus et et donc je
comprends il faut qu'il y ait des mises
au point mais je pense que l'intérêt
général fait que l'intérêt général et
l'intérêt bien compris de la famille
radicale c'est de rester évidemment pas
d'inquiétude non j'ai j'ai du souci j'ai
pas d'inquiétude j'ai du souci des
personnes j'ai des soucis du respect des
des des personnes je je comprends qu'il
soit blessé voilà et ça me souciit et
çaag quand même un des derniers alliés
du parti du
gouvernement radicau de
gauche oui mais j'ai pas beaucoup
d'inquiétude sur cet aspect là des
choses d'accord
voilà et sur les vers et sur les Verts
est- est-ce que le débat actuel sur la
transition énergétique va va permettre
de de ressouder l'alliance entre
guillemets entre gverement la semaine
dernière la journée parlementaire des
des vers sénateurs et députés Segolen
Royal y est allé Claude bartelogne y est
allé j'y suis allé nous avons été très
bien accueillis nous avons eu un
dialogue assez fructueux et vous avez
raison de dire que sur l'acte majeur de
ce quinquena s'agissant des problèmes
j'allais dire de nature écologique c'est
la transition énergétique j'ai bon
espoir que les vers votent ce texte et
d'ailleurs d'autres à l'intérieur de
l'Assemblée c'est un texte très
important
euh et qui rassemble qui rassemble la
gauche mais qui rassemble y compris
au-delà et qui apaise c'estàd dans ce
paysex d'espoir à gauche oui et
d'apaisement et d'apaisement pour la
société française et d'avenir parce que
il y a de l'emploi il y a de l'énergie
il y a y a plein de choses positives
Cécile Duflot a dit qu'elle était plus
socialiste qu'Emmanuel Vals comment
est-ce que vous avez interprété cette
pique une de plus bon pas de commentaire
à faire c'est si elle veut prendre sa
carte elle vient il y a pas de problème
je l'ai déjà accueilli à par Paris comme
candidate aux élections législatives
est-ce que vous regrettez est-ce que
vous regrettez que le parti socialist d'
avoir dû lui faire de la place vous av
où ou mais à l'époque moi je l'avais
aidé ah vous l'aviez aidé aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous regrettez que elle je
regrette qu'elle avait pris de la
distance par rapport à la fois à
l'engagement qui était le sien au moment
où nous étions candidats et puis par
rapport à cette majorité je lui ai dit
elle le sait voilà maintenant moi j'ai
bon espoir encore une fois que une fois
qu'on vous savez le le retour de la
droite on a malheureusement pas trop
parlé mais les programmes à 100
milliards d'euros et cetera la fin de la
fonction publique les les les les les
39hur payé
35 vous voyez qu'il y a des sources
d'économie proposé par la droite vous
les cherchiez tout à l'heure non non je
les cherche dans le scénar je cherche
dans les textes les blab bla les
blabblas de congrès je sais j'attends de
voir s'il le vote d'accord merci merci
Jean-M merci perine la semaine prochaine
perine notre invité sera le nouveau
patron du groupe um au Sénat on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans le reportage
Monsieur R
merci à tous bonsoir à très
vite ça c'est c'est ce que je dis à
manuel très simplement faut pas se
crisper pourquoi d'ailleurs se crisper
il faut simplement
discuter faut pas se crisper manuel
est-ce un conseil d'amis ou un désaveux
sainglan après les députés et les
ministres frondeurs martinri a fait son
retour dans l'arène mais que cachent ces
déclarations quel est son objectif et
pourquoi les débats entre les
socialistes atteignent aujourd'hui ce
degré de violence cette semaine nous
déabillons en tout bien tout honneur un
pouvoir en pleine
discorde déshabillonsles samedi à 23h45
sur public
Senna bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle édition de 24h Sénat
voici les titres le nouveau visage du
Sénat les présidences de commission sur
le point d'être attribué la socialiste
Michel André prend la tête de la
commission des finances le sénateur UMP
Philippe Bas les lois Hervé Moré le
centriste sera en charge du
développement durable le détail dans ce
journal la nouvelle affaire de Nicolas
Sarkozi d'après les révélations du
journal Le Monde la justice enquête sur
d'éventuelles rétrocommission lors de
contrat de vente d'hélicoptère signé
sous son quinquena en 2010 avec le
Kazakhstan la nouvelle menace de
Bruxelles la Commission européenne
serait prête à censurer le budget
français si le gouvernement ne trouve
pas 8 milliards d'euros d'économie ou de
recettes supplémentaires débat à suivre
dans cette édition mais avant de
dérouler tous ces titres manuel WS le
Premier ministre a redit l'opposition de
la France à la gestation pour autrui
tout en assurant que la réflexion
engagée sur le cas des enfants nés de
GPA à l'étranger et vivant en France
allait se poursuivre le temps nécessaire
il répondait ainsi à une question de la
députée Europe Écologie les ver
Véronique massonau on l'écoute c'était
cet après-midi lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale pour le
gouvernement pour le président de la
République ce débat est tranché il est
tranché depuis le début du quinquena la
France est opposé à la GPA parce qu'elle
est opposée au nom de ses valeurs au nom
du progrès et de l'humanisme à toute
forme de commercialisation des êtres
humains et d'expérimentation en ce
domaine et en disant cela et en
disanceela madame la députée je n'ignore
pas la souffrance de ceux qui voudrai
tant transmettre et je ne ni pas le
désir d'enfant
inassouvis je vous le disais en titre on
connaît désormais le nouveau visage du
Sénat l'ancienne ministre PS Michel
André qui sera notre invité dans un
instant sera la future présidente de la
commission des finances du Sénat de son
côté le groupe UMP a choisi au poste
stratégique de rapporteur général du
budget alberériic de montolfier sénateur
d' Loir retour sur cette journée qui a
forcément fait des déçus avec Quentin
calm et Tam TR nuit première réunion de
groupe depuis le renouvellement du Sénat
vivement que l'installation soit
terminée vivement que on se mette
vraiment au travail mais c'est un
passage obligé il faut le faire on le
fait dans la bonne humeur dans la joie
avec un groupe rassemblé un groupe
rassemblé au grand complet pour choisir
ses représentants au bureau du Sénat
auutour de Gérard Larcher dernières
négociation les sénateurs du groupe
s'isolent pour voter j' voter pour toi à
Hu clos résultat alberric de montolfier
devient rapporteur de la commission des
finances c'est une tâche qui n'est
absolument pas un honneur je crois que
c'est un travail très ingrat surtout
avec le budget qui nous attend un budget
qui va être extrêmement difficile nous
sommes désormais un sénat qui est un
Sénat dans l'opposition dans
l'opposition c'est pas détruire détricôé
tout ce qui se fait de la part de la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
aussi proposer une autre
candidat malheureux au plateau l'ancien
Premier ministre Jean-Pierre rafarin
hérite quant à lui de la commission des
affaires étrangères il n'y avait pas
d'autres candidat je suis heureux que
mon groupe m en effet soutenu Philippe B
prend la tête de la commission des lois
nous allons conjuguer un travail
technique de qualité qui est la marque
du Sénat avec une très forte ambition
politique de parler en faveur de
l'alternance par des démonstrations
concrètes que seront nos votes et les
textes que nous
adopterons noir hérite quant à lui de la
commission des affaires économiques et
Jean-Claude godudin d'un poste de
vice-président du Sénat même processus
chez les socialistes mais moins d'enjeux
c'est la commission des finances la
seule présidée par un sénateur de gauche
qui aiguise les appétits finalement
Michel Andr obtient le poste les
socialistes ont choisi mon nom et bien
je suis fier et je les remercie beaucoup
elle a été préféré à l'ancienne ministre
Nicole brick moins consensuel trois
autres socialistes obtiennent une
viceprésident aujourd'hui Françoise
Cartron Jean-Pierre cafet et Claude
Berry Desbat enfin de des trois
questeurs du Sénat ont été choisis
Bernard SuG pour l'UMP et Dominique B
pour les
socialistes nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir Tam bons alors vous avez
suivi toute cette journée et bien
d'élection dans les groupes le PS l'UMP
et les communistes ont désigné leurs
candidats au poste clé du Sénat quelle
lecture faites-vous de cette nouvelle
distribution des cartes écoutez on sent
comme un vent de renouveau et pourant
temps c'était pas forcément bien parti
hein il faut dire qu'avec la réélection
de Gérard Larcher au plateau lui qui a
été Président du Sénat de 2008 à 2011 on
en était pas sûr et finalement et bien
l'arché 2 ne ressemblera pas à l'arché 1
alors le symbole de tout ça c'est tout
de même le grand bouleversement à la
commission des finances du Sénat où la
socialiste Michel André ex
viice-présidente et bien devient
présidente du la Commission et puis
c'est l'UMP alberérique de Mongolfier
qui devient lui rapporteur et cela alors
qu'il y avait des poil qui sétait
présenté Nicole brick ou encore Philippe
Marini qui tous deux avaient été
rapporteur et président de la commission
des finances alors ces élections
internes en elles-même sont des
nouveautés et oui ça tous les sénateurs
nous l'ont confié nous l'ont confirmé à
droite comme à gauche il y a 3 ans et
bien ils avaient et bien une liste
présentée par le président de groupe et
il devaient juste adouber les candidats
et tout ça était un petit peu opaque
cette fois-ci bien tout a changé c'est
un vrai vote un exercice démocratique
chaque cand candidat s'est présenté
pendant quelques minutes quelques
minutes pour convaincre ses collègues un
Minig grant oral et puis tous ont voté à
huclos et puis la parité également a été
un petit peu mise en avant par exemple
au niveau du groupe UMP et bien les
sénateurs avaient le choix ils avaient
seulement le choix entre un
vice-président homme et une
vice-présidente femme en l'occurrence ça
a été Jean-Claude godudin c'était assez
attendu et puis Isabelle Debré petit
bémol toutefois là où la parité n'était
pas obligatoire et bien ce sont souvent
des hommes qui ont été élus comme quoi
on ne change pas tout non plus d'un coup
de baguette magique alors finalement th
les grands déessus ce soir ce sont les
habitués au poste à responsabilité qui
étit jusquel reconduit d'année en année
hein et oui et Philippe marinii par
exemple et bien s'est éclipsé dès la
réunion avant la fin avant que les
autres sénateurs sortent avant même de
connaître les résultats il devait
l'anticiper cette défaite pour lui qui a
été 16 ans durant rapporteur de la
commission des finances puis président
de la commission des finances et bien
c'est vraiment l'emblème de ce
changement de génération et puis c'est
aussi un coup de Massu pour celui qui
était il y a quelques jours encore
candidat au plateau merci beaucoup Tam
et puis on connaîtra demain les
candidats du groupe udi UC du Sénat une
proposition de loi a été déposée par la
sénatrice centriste Nathalie Goulet
objectif de ce texte qui sera présenté
le 9 octobre à la commission de la
culture conforter je cite le statut
juridique des rédactions pour protéger
les journalistes d'éventuelles pression
en leur donnant la possibilité de réagir
sur le terrain du droit on l'écoute au
micro de Jonathan
on est quand même là pour pour compléter
l'arsenal juridique quand il est
nécessaire et et je crois que c'est une
c'est une vraie nécessité de de protéger
la rédaction en tant que telle on voit
bien ce qui peut se passer aujourd'hui
avec LCI avec lib avec Rue 89 et et
beaucoup d'autres titres pour lesquels
les rédactions sont ni informé ni
protégé donc j'espère que ce texte va
connaître sa vie normale parlementaire
au sein de la commission des affaires
culturelles les Radicaux de Gauche en
col contre le Parti socialiste il menace
de quitter la majorité si de nouvelles
règles du jeu ne sont pas édictées
reportage au groupe RDSE du Sénat Cécile
Sixou première réunion du groupe RDSE ce
matin après leur défaite au sénatorial
et avec quatre sièges en moins mais
aussi l'échec de leur figure
emblématique Jean-Michel baayet les
sénateurs du Parti radical de gauche
sont amè je réponds quand j'ai envie de
répondre c'est
clair sont remontés contre leurs alliés
socialistes on peut pas dire quand même
qu'aux élections on a toujours été
soutenu de manière très forte et ferme
bon voà c'est vrai queon av quand même
eu des des pertes et qu'on aurait pensé
que avec les accords que nous avions on
pouvait dans certain département je
pense à l'UR et Loire par exemple et
bien avoir un él sénateur du coup
quitter le navire majoritaire les
membres du Parti radical de gauche au
Sénat y pensent nous verrons comment les
choses se passent lorsque nous aurons
fait un travail en commission ce qui n'a
pas ce qui n'a pas été fait nous sommes
dans la mise en place donc
toute position que nous pourrions
prendre pourrait être démentie demain ne
plus soutenir le Parti socialiste au
Sénat ni à l'Assemblée nationale voire
même quitter le gouvernement les avis au
sein du groupe radical au Sénat sont
divisés je ne connaais pas vraiment les
les causes qui expliqueraient qu'à
quelques jours d'intervalle
on entre dans un gouvernement on donne
sa confiance au gouvernement et qu'on en
sort c'est au PRG qu'il appartient dans
desci en décidé demain il devrait se
mettre d'accord sur une position lors de
leur bureau national en attendant en
coulisse Jean-Michel baayet est à la
manœuvre reçu de manière informelle par
François Hollande et manuel Vals cet
après-midi il devrait renégocier les
bases de leur soutien 24h Sénat tout de
suite
l'invité
et notre invité ce soir Claudie Lebreton
bonsoir vous êtes président de
l'association des département de France
l'ADF qui tenait aujourd'hui son bureau
à quelques semaines du Congrès qui se
tiendra à poau au mois de novembre alors
on imagine que le bureau a été marqué
par la réforme territoriale qui est dans
tous les esprits est-ce que il y a une
position qui a évolué sur notamment les
propositions faite par Manuel Vals qui
après avoir envisagé la suppression des
départements en 2020 à propos er trois
options pour conserver trois échelons
différents du conseil général cet
après-midi nous avons tenu une réunion
de bureau et il y a eu un vote solennel
sur un texte que j'ai présenté une
plateforme concernant la réforme des
collectivités territoriales et ce texte
a été votter à l'unanimité de tous les
membres du bureau quel que soit leur
sensibilité politique et que contient-il
ce texte cl ce texte d'abord il partle
d'une position de principe qui répond à
votre observation le Conseil
départemental qui sera élu en mars
prochain à vivra jusque en 2020 puisque
le président de la République a dit pour
supprimer les départements il faut une
révision constitutionnelle le Premier
ministre a annoncé pour l'après 2020 la
Fédération des intercommunalités le
modèle Lionnais dans les métropole et le
maintien du département mux rural il
veut que nous en discutions mais c'est
la préparation d'un nouveau texte à
venir donc aujourd'hui nous nous avons
deux objectifs à travers ce texte c'est
de discuter de la loi nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
République et les éventuels transferts
de compétences vers les régions et la
deuxième enjeu auquel nous sommes
confrontés c'est incontestablement la
loi de finances 2015 h alors justement
cette loi de finances de 2015 avec cette
baisse des dotations pour les
collectivités quelle est la position de
l'Assemblée des départements de France
il faut le dire aux téléspectateurs les
conseils généraux ont une compétence
essentielle c'est le financement de la
cohésion sociale les solidarités des
allocations pour les personnes âgées
retraité le RA la pas l'Allocation
Personnalisée de toute l'action sociale
la protection de l'enfance des
compétences qui sont pas toujours
connues et qui représentent 38 milliards
d'euros et aujourd'hui vous savez que
avec Jean-Marc herud le Premier ministre
d'Alor nous avions signé un accord le 16
juillet 16 juillet 2013 qui permettait
au département de percevoir à peu près
avec des DMTO 2 milliards d'euros pour
pouvoir financer les allocations
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
nouvelle négociation avec le
gouvernement pour la loi de 2015 et on
voit bien que on demande au département
1illard 200 million d'euros alors que
l'an dernier et on a trouvé une solution
donc on est en discussion pour trouver
là aussi des solutions sur le
financement de la cohésion sociale et
discussion sur et quelles sont les
pistes qui peuvent être envisagé puis
l'investissement public oui est-ce que
les départements ne doivent pas non plus
un peu contribuer à cet effort de
redressement des compte public les
départements sont prêts à contribuer
depuis 2002 date des lois sur le social
la part de Lionel jusemin à l'époque et
bien nous avons économisé sur nos
ressources propres tenez-vous bien 48
milliards d'euros
pour financer les allocations et la
cohésion sociale donc nous avons été
exemplaires sur le sujet mais
aujourd'hui on veut que le financement
de la solidarité soit assumé en partie
par l'État et en partie par les
collectivités départementales et nous
pensons que la croissance aujourd'hui
des allocations qui est 1 milliard
d'euros supplémentaires que au moins le
gouvernement en prenne une large part et
qu'on puisse aussi discuter de la
péréquation financière entre les
départements modestes et les
départements riches alors autre thème
qui a été abordé et aujourd'hui lors du
bureau ce sont les assises de la
ruralité qu'en est-il exactement Claudie
Lebreton alors les assises de la
ruralité il faut pas que ce soit je veux
dire pour le gouvernement simplement une
opportunité ou un gadget et il y a
autour de cette question des moi ce que
j'appelle les nouvelles ruralités hein
parce que ça peut avoir plusieurs
caractères et bien le gouvernement qui
parle souvent des métropoles des grandes
régions il faut avoir le souci aussi de
ces millions d'habitants qui habitent
dans les territoires ruraux qui doivent
avoir non pas une réponse
institutionnelle dans un premier temps
mais c'est quel modèle économique nous
voulons porter sur ces territoires
ruraux donct pour coup sont dynamiques
très innovants travaillent sur les cuit
cours sur une nouvelle économie de
nouvell solidarité et c'est bien que on
puisse avoir des temps pour en parler
avec le gouvernement et bien merci
Claudie Lebreton d'avoir été notre
invité ce soir rendez-vous est pris pour
le congrès de l'ADF à c'est au mois de
novembre prochain merci à vous merci
bonsoir la transition énergétique en
débat à l'Assemblée nationale socialiste
écologi ont travaillé main dans la main
en commission mais il reste encore des
désaccords le texte devrait arriver très
prochainement au Sénat les enjeux de ce
projet de loi avec Stéphane Beaujard et
thbao
Perry c'est le projet phare de l'automne
la loi sur la transition énergétique
objectif principal réduire de 50 % la
consommation d'énergie française d'ici à
2050 pour y parvenir la loi encourage la
rénovation des bâtiments au norme basse
consommation et le développement des
transports plus propres avec la mise en
avant de l'électrique et de l'hybride
autre levier pour agir les énergies
renouvelables elle représente
aujourd'hui 15 % de la production
d'électricité cette part doit doubler en
2030 des décisions qui vont dans le bon
sens pour les parlementaires verts c'est
une une loi qui pour la première fois
remet la planification énergétique au
cœur de de l'appareil
d'État avec une visibilité une
programmation plurannuel à à à 10 ans du
débat collectif pourtant un point reste
flou le nucléaire avec 58 réacteurs la
France est le deuxème producteur mondial
la loi prévoit un passage de 75 à 50 %
de la production d'énergie nucléaire
d'ici à 2025 mais rien sur les
fermetures des centrales notamment
celles de Fessenheim un manque de
visibilité qui agace au sein du parti
écologiste c'est une déception que fenim
soit pas encore fermé c'est sûr c'était
une promesse on sait que le lobby de DF
est extrêmement fort mais encore une
fois il faut expliquer que en fermant
fessonheim on économise de l'argent
parce qu'en fait si on le le renouvelle
si on l'améliore si on la rénove aux
normes de sécurité actuelle c'est un
gouffre financier et pendant ce temps-là
elle est dangereuse le coût de
l'ensemble des mesures est estimé à 10
milliards d'euros les débats autour des
64 articles vont se poursuivre toute la
semaine vote solennel le 14 octobre à
l'assemblée avant d'atterrir au Sénat
pour une seule lecture 24h Sénat le
débat le projet de loi de finances pour
2015 va-t-il être retoqué par la
Commission européenne Bruxelles presse
Paris de revoir sa copie même si manuel
Vals assure que l'Union ne peut pas
rejeter le budget de la France les
explications de ilonet Schultz
8 milliards d'euros c'est le montant
divulgué ce matin dans la presse une
somme correspondante aux économies que
le gouvernement pourrait devoir trouver
tout ça pour apaiser les foudres de
Bruxelles car contrairement à ce qu'elle
avait promis la France ne devrait pas
respecter ses engagements elle annonce
un déficit de 4,3 % loin des trois
promis il y a 2 ans pourtant le budget
2015 prévoit déjà 21 milliards d'euros
d'économie pas question donc d'aller
plus loin au moment où nous amorçons la
baisse des impôts vous croyez qu'on va
aller dire maintenant ah bah bien
finalement on va les augmenter non ce
serait incohérent pour justifier ces
mauvais résultats la France invoque des
circonstances exceptionnelles un
argument qui passe de moins en moins
auprès des autres pays notamment ceux
qui ont consenti d'importants sacrifices
pourtant devant les députés cet
après-midi manuel Vals reste ferme nous
pensons qu'avec les choix que nous
faisons pour les entreprises et pour la
croissance c'est le budget qu'il faut à
la France de toute façon la Commission
européenne ne peut pas le ministre des
Finances l'a encore rappelé ce matin ne
peut pas rejeter non mais elle peut à
terme infliger une amende soit 4
milliards d'euros en flexibilité côté
français l'assitude à Bruxelles se
dirige-ton vers un clash l'hypothèse est
peu probable José Manuel Baroso tout
comme Jean-Claude Junker préférerait
soigner leur sortie et entré respective
à la tête de la commission le mauvais
élève comme ses camarades a jusqu'au 15
octobre pour rendre sa copie et on ouvre
le débat avec nos invités ce soir
fabianne Keller bonsoir sénateur UMP
Dubin merci d'être avec nous avec nous
également sur ce plateau Michel André
bonsoir sénatrice socialiste du P d'au
et futur présidente de la commission des
finances du Sénat félicitations et merci
d'être avec nous ma première question
s'adresse à vous Michel André est-ce que
c'est une menace à prendre au sérieux
cette censure ce rejet probable par
Bruxelles du projet de budget de de la
France voilà plusieurs années que nous
devons faire passer nos projections nos
projets par Bruxelles c'est nouveau
c'est c'est c'est des choses qui se
mettent en œuvre peu à peu qui parfois
sont plus aisés que d'autres lorsqu'on a
plus de croissance on a moins de
difficultés certes et lorsque le chômage
s'installe comme il l'a fait nous voyons
bien que nous avons un conflit complet
alors je pense que l'Europe elle é elle
évolue elle évolue beaucoup depuis
toujours avec des des morceaux de crise
qui que la France est dans le déis
puisquon a l'impression quand on entend
encore manuel Vals qui dit et bien non
ce n'est pas possible qui prend
peut-être ses men la question c'est
c'est s'il faut supprimer des postes de
fonctionnair c'est qui c'est des
infirmières des institutrices des
policiers des gendarmes voilà moi je je
pense qu'il faut être attentif il faut
être sérieux effectivement tendre vers
cet objectif mais je pense que le le
délai sans doute doit être difficile
puis moi je me souviens je ne veux pas
agresser ma collègue Fabienne Keller
mais je me souviens que en 2007 entre
2002 et 2007 le Président de la
République était allé à Bruxell pour
dire moi je ne respecterai pas donc le
dérapage il a commencé il y a longtemps
je pense qu'on a besoin de retrouver un
espace peut-être collectivement tout
Français fa réagissait c'est pas une
agression mais bon une petite remarque
quand même sur ce déficit budgétaire
effectivement que la France traîne comme
un boulet depuis des années absolument
je crois qu'il faut regarder la réalité
en face et la France est de plus en plus
isolé en Europe c'est le seul pays dont
les critères principaux de chômage de
déficit budgétaire s'agrave et se
détériore
simultanément cela nécessite des efforts
réels par exemple sur la réorganisation
indispensable de l'État faut faire un
travail de fond faut trouver des
économies on a beaucoup décentralisé il
faut donc économie sur l'appareil d'État
il ne faut pas non plus afficher des
chiffres comme les 21 milliards
d'économie qui ne sont pas documenté on
ne sait pas comment ces économies seront
réalisées et donc c'est la crédibilité
de la France qui a été affaiblie vous
l'avez démontré dans votre reportage les
la croissance qui pardon le déficit
budgétaire qui finalement est bien plus
important que prévu donc nous devons
tenir compte du fait que les économies
européennes sont intégrées aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas avoir une stratégie
distincte des autres États-membres parce
qu'il y a beaucoup d'échanges parce que
les travailleurs se déplacent donc faire
le bras de faire avec
Bruxelles je crois qu'il faut aussi
respecter le regard et l'analyse de la
commission qui sent que la France
s'enfonce et nous devons entendre ce
message Michel André effectivement il y
a cette question aussi du crédit de
l'image de la France on voit bien que
Manuel Vals qui fait la tournée
européenne de ses homologues et bien a
du mal à convaincre de relancer et la
croissance est-ce que est-ce que par
rapport juste à une visite un moment un
affichage une manière de de dire qu'on
aime les entreprises on peut juger de
comment se fait euh le crédit et le
tricotage fin euh des relation du
gouvernement français avec les autres
gouvernements je pense que ça
demanderait un peu plus de temps sans
doute et un peu plus d'analyse sur des
questions complexes certes nous devons
euh nous devons aller dans le même sens
mais certainement on voit encore un
autre exemple avec Pierre moscoviss qui
a eu du mal à convaincre lors de son
audition et bien aussi
euh élève ou alors ou alors on peut dire
mais je sais pas si cette histoire
d'élèv bon élève mauvaise élève n'est
pas une manière de considérer la
question qui est curieuse et infantile
alors isolement de la France dis pay
sont pas des élèves et et je considère
que dans les graves crises celle de la
Grèce celle de du Portugal de l'Espagne
qui globalement est toujours un peu en
difficulté adm onle on on a pu penser
qu'il y avait des outils à mettre en
œuvre dont peut-être la France
aujourd'hui peut s'emparer pour essayer
de limiter les dégâts je crois que c'est
vraiment pas un match contre Bruxelles
c'est une situation très difficile dans
laquelle est la France il faut la
regarder en face attention aux mauvaises
solutions je pense par exemple à la
baisse des dotations des collectivités
locales 11 milliards hein sur sur 3 ans
on peut penser qu'il y aura un effet
boomerang c'est-à-dire que
ces sommes non versées aux collectivités
c'est moins d'investissement donc moins
d'impôts sur les sociétés moins de
cotisation sociale on peut estimer à 4
ou 5 milliards la perte la même année et
sur le RSA et les aides sociales hein
puisquil y aura des chômeurs en plus
autant sur les années suivantes donc
c'est pas une bonne économie c'est une
économie de fonctionnement pour
économies sur la structure de l'État sur
un certain nombre de dispositifs qui
sont à guichet ouvert qu'il faut
analyser sereinement et je crois que le
a cette responsabilité particulière de
faire un travail de fond alors justement
he c'est la nouvelle présidente de la
commission des finances comment vous
allez travailler oui mais par exemple
sur les aides sociales dont les montants
pour l'État mais aussi pour les
départements ne cessent d'augmenter très
fortement alors que en parallèle la
pauvreté augmente aussi regardons et
faisons des choix la difficulté
financière dans laquelle est la France
aujourd'hui l'impose et puis évitons les
arbitrages politicar il y a un excellent
article aujourd'hui de Monsieur picketti
euh socialiste dans
Libération qui décrit le cice cette aide
aux entreprises qui n'est rien qui n'est
tout sauf efficace c'est au lieu de
réduire les charges pour les entreprises
qu'elle puisse calculer ce que coûte un
salarié si elle le recrute c'est un
remboursement 18 mois plus tard des
charges sociales supplémentaires réglé
donc ça n'a pas d'effet un rapport
récent la montré sur les embauches donc
il faut aussi faire face avec courage là
governvernement socialiste a trop
souvent construit des
compromispositif à revoir pour faire des
économies il il est vraiment très tôt et
Fabien Keller c'est bien c'est c'est
dans la durée un peu qu'il faut évaluer
évaluer le CIC aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
possible une première évaluation donc il
y a des choses qui qui fonctionn
certaines dans certaines structures on a
eu des des des retours de de grandes
surface par exemple qui estime qu'elles
peuvent salarier un peu plus longtemps
les salariés à temps partiel que sont
les femmes euh dans d'autres endroits il
y aura un choix d'investissement je
pense qu'il est tô pour évaluer
aujourd'hui le cice et et la difficulté
que nous avons c'est bien dans le temps
long comment nous adaptons les outils
plus fins c'est ça la difficulté mais
elle est pas nouvelle cette année Michel
André Fabien Keller a dit aussi que ça
serait au rôle du Sénat alors en tant
que nouvelle présidente de la commission
des finances comment je je dis futur
c'est quasiment fait on va dire comment
entendez-vous bien travailler dans un
sénat de droite mais j'ai déjà moi
exercé des responsabilités de
vice-président dans un Sénat où la
majorité est à l'UMP euh je pense qu'il
y a un respect entre nous suffisant et
dans la commission nous aurons la même
chose et nous sortons de d'un couple
rapporteur général socialiste président
UMP et nous avons nous avons travaillé
nous avons avancé nous avons amendé
parfois et si nous n'avons pas adopté
vous travaillerez que le l'UMP
alberrique de monolfie he qui sera
certainement rapporteur général du Budet
ou naturellement mais naturellement
parce que nous sommes appelés à
travailler ensemble et si nous voulons
corriger profondément un certain nombre
de difficultés dans notre pays nous
avons intérêt à travailler ensemble
fabiien Keller oui écoutez c'est tout à
fait l'esprit l'état d'esprit du du
groupe UMP auquel je participe de la
nouvelle présidence du du Sénat être une
opposition constructive qui par exemple
sur les dotations aux collectivités
essaiera de faire un travail positif
parce que je crois que c'est vraiment la
fausse bonne solution qui pénalisera
l'État lui-même et sur d'autres sujets
peut-être retrouverons-nous des clivages
plus traditionnels croyez vraiment à
cette opposition constructive ou c'est
juste une formule toute faite non je
crois que nous pouvons c'est plutôt
notre tradition au Sénat essayer de
trouver des axes stratégiques sur
lesquels l'accord peut-être plus large
que un seul parti d'un côté ou de
l'autre par exemple sur la réforme
indispensable de la fonction publique je
pense qu'elle doit être ouverte la
fonction publique d'État à la fonction
publique territoriale et hospitalière ce
n'est que dans la durée sur 5 à 10 ans
qu'on pourra faire évoluer les choses
pour cela il faut construire un
consensus pour que l'action publique
soit conduite dans la durée Michel André
sur cette formule l'opposition
constructive c'est ce qu'a dit Gérard
Larché véritablement si si on est au
Sénat depuis longtemps c'est mon cas et
Fabienne kellerement nous ne sommes pas
des jeunes sénatrices nous avons de
l'expérience nous savons bien parfois
que l'amélioration sensible apporté par
la commission des finances sur les
projets de lois de finances quel que
soit le président quel que soit
rapporteur général a été pour beaucoup
dans la bonne qualité de la loi moi mon
regret c'est que nous n'ayons pas adopté
les deux dernières années la première
partie de la loi de finance qui nous a
pas permis d'étudier la seconde finement
le projet loi de finance a plus de
chance d'être adopté sous un sénat et
bien à droite qu'un sén à gauche ce que
vous ditesich quel que soit droite ou
gauche l'important c'est que le Sénat
joue son rôle parce que en ne le faisant
pas il a donné l'impression qu'il ne
servait à rien c'est gravisse alors
c'est intéressant puisque nous avons
rejeté la première partie c'est-à-dire
en gros la fiscalité
ce qui nous a pas permis de débattre de
la deè pare c'estàd les dépenses des
ministères donc les les grandes
politique publque ça ne se passera pas
avec un Sénat à droite nous verrons cela
dépend de l'ouverture du gouvernement
pour prendre en compte les améliorations
que proposera le Sénat au premier rang
desquel le traitement des collectivités
territoriales vous savez les communes
nous sortons de campagne sénatoriale ce
sont des énergies sur les territoires
l'État est en train de est désespéré en
tirant le tapis en renonçant aux
dotations en transférant des compétences
sans aucun financement donc il faut
laisser les acteurs qui créent qui
s'investissent donner toute leur énergie
et trouver des économies durables et de
fond un bon Buet mais il faut un gouvern
il faudrait parler tout là Fabien Keller
parle des dotations mais les
collectivités ont d'autres types de
ressources qu'il on sait bien qu'il y a
il y a des des pourcentages en plus sur
C aotation voilà donc regardons
l'ensemble merci mesame merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation ce soir c'est
la fin de cette édition à 22h vous
retrouvez Sonia mabrook très bonne
soirée à
demain